I'm doing a little surprise date night tonight for my husband and I,
and I'm here at the dollar store,
and they have this big selection of really random,
odd movies you've never heard of before,
and we are gonna watch one tonight for date night.
Exit plan. We have Cage Fighter,
American Buffalo.
Are these even real movies?
Desert Dancer,
dream dare dance.
I almost got this one,
but I didn't think my husband would like it.
The Warriors way.
Just so many. And who knows,
maybe there are some good ones in here.
I ended up looking at the horror movies,
and this one stuck out to me called Blue Cough.
So I got it. I got a popcorn container,
I got some candy,
and we sat down and watched it after the kids went to sleep.
It was about an MT
who became haunted and had all these weird experiences.
It was really hard to follow.
It was really cheesy.
It was not a good movie.
But it was a really,
really fun date night.